really is this what you're doing to us
tonight
giving us tonight look stunning tell me
about this you know
I guess it's just it's it's a Dream It's
a dream it's very tight I need to undo
it and breathe in a minute but what is
it corseted it's corseted
and it's strapped and tied and gloved
and sequenced you're all in there oh
listen I'm chilling I love Turtles I'm
chilling tonight for real
a long time ago
we lost
your first single and it hits number one
how do you top that
[Music]
I know you guys you know you became a
family on screen you've been working on
this since 2020 how much of a family did
you become with everybody officer I mean
we're like they are like my second
family and I think that was one of the
most
um wonderful parts of this experience is
I gained a second family
what's your favorite memory from band
camp when you guys win oh my gosh
um I think when we started
um being able to play together because
there was a long time where we were
working on our instruments and things
alone and then once we were good enough
they put us together in the same room
and that was really
um exciting because we all got to work
together and run to the songs so what
happens when this album comes out and
folks start screaming for a tour what
are you gonna do we've said this before
for me you need to ask Amazon we're all
happy to go into it you're ready to go I
don't know if we're ready
we'd be happy to you know the fans of
this book are so passionate how
satisfied do you think they're going to
be once they see it oh my gosh I mean
that's their you know that's a big
pressure you know I mean the one thing
I'll say is that Taylor's happy and I
feel like if Taylor's happy then
hopefully the fans should be happy
here's the 64 million dollar question
eagle-eyed viewers at Entertainment
Tonight have noticed that your husband
may have made a brief cameo
in episode two is that correct yes you
did I don't want to like spoil it but he
The Producers thought it would be funny
if he was in that scene so they just
came and asked you guys if it was yeah
they were like do you want Ben to do
this and I was like yeah that's
hilarious that's pretty cool that was
probably a fun moment for the two of you
it was very funny
you look great who were these earrings
because they're sick I think they're a
house oh oh they're scrap rally sorry I
was wearing House of Harlow earlier yes
like my dress I know great have a great
time tonight good to see you baby girl
[Music]
thank you